>>> HELLO.
I'M IN NEW YORK.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
RIGHT NOW, A CATASTROPHIC
SITUATION UNFOLDING IN KENTUCKY.
30 PEOPLE ARE DEAD AND HUNDREDS
ARE UNACCOUNTED FOR AND
OFFICIALS ARE RACING OUT TO BEAT
THE INTENSE HEAT THAT IS IN THE
FORECAST FOR LATER THIS WEEK.
BUT FINDING SURVIVORS IS
DIFFICULT.
BRIDGES AND ROADS ARE WASHED
AWAY, VITAL POWER IS OUT AND THE
THREAT OF MORE RAIN IS STILL
HANGING OVER THIS VERY SATURATED
REGION.
A NEW FLOOD WATCH WAS ISSUED
OVERNIGHT FOR THE EASTERN PART
OF THE STATE.
WE ARE LEARNING MORE TODAY ABOUT
THOSE WHO ESCAPED THE WATERS AND
MORE ABOUT THOSE WHO DID NOT.
LIVES AND FAMILIES FOREVER
CHANGED.
EVAN KICKS OFF OUR COVERAGE IN
HAZARD, KENTUCKY.
TELL US WHAT YOU'VE BEEN SEEING.
>> Reporter: WE HAVE BEEN BY
THIS CREEK IN ROUTE 128 IN PERRY
COUNTY, ONE MUCH HARDEST HIT
COUNTIES.
YOU CAN SEE THE WATER LEVEL THAT
THEY ARE STILL DEALING WITH HERE
AFTER THIS FLOOD THAT CAME
THROUGH.
THIS CREEK FLOODED OVER, YOU
KNOW, EIGHT OR TEN FEET FROM
HERE, TAKING A WHOLE HOUSE WITH
IT AND KNOCKING OUT THE BOTTOM
OF THIS BUILDING TO MIME RIGHT.
THE WATER LEVEL HAS BEEN GOING
SUSPEND.
WE HAVE BEEN RAIN THROUGHOUT THE
DAY.
YOU SEE THE YELLOW ROAD SIGN IS
OUR GUY.
IT WAS RAINING SMORNG AND THE
WATER TO THE TOP OF THAT ROCK
AND EMERGE THAT SIGN BUT COME
BACK DOWN NOW.
THERE IS MORE RAIN IN THE
FORECAST AND A FLOOD WATCH IS IN
EFFECT FOR TONIGHT.
THE PROBLEM IS THE CREEK IS
REALLY HIGH AND THEY CAN'T TAKE
MUCH WATER.
NOBODY IS EXPECTING A FLOOD
SURGE LIKE WE SAW ON THURSDAY
THAT WAS A HISTORIC FLOOD SURGE
BUT IT WON'T TAKE MUCH FOR THERE
TO BE MORE DAMAGE HERE BECAUSE
THE GROUND IS SATURATED AND SO
MUCH WATER AROUND THE CREEKS AND
STREAMS AND THINGS THAT HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE
WATER THAT ALREADY CAME THROUGH.
IT'S A SCARY SITUATION.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE FORECAST AND
MORE WATER IS ON THE WAY.
RIGHT NOW, IT'S SUNNY BUT COULD
GET REALLY BAD REALLY FAST.
>> Reporter: YOU'RE LEARNING
ABOUT THE VICTIMS, INCLUDING
FOUR CHILDREN.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL US?
>> Reporter: THAT'S RIGHT.
THE SAD STORY OF FOUR SIBLINGS,
YOUNG CHILDREN ALL DIED TOGETHER
IN THESE FLOODS.
I ASSUME YOU'RE SHOWING THE
PICTURE RIGHT NOW.
I CAN'T SEE IT.
WE ARE OUT HERE OPERATEDING IN
THE TECHNICAL WORLD THAT WE
HAVE.
THAT PICTURE SPEAKS VOLUMES
ABOUT WHAT HAS GONE ON IN THIS
AREA.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WITH PICTURES
IN THEIR HANDS ALL OVER THIS
COMMUNITY TRYING TO FIND PEOPLE
THEY HAVEN'T HEARD FROM SINCE
THE FLOODWATERS ROSE.
THEY HOPE THEY ARE ALIVE AND
HAVE WATER AND SUPPLIES.
IN THE CASE OF THOSE CHILDREN,
IT'S TRAGIC AS YOU CAN IMAGINE.
WHEN WE HEAR UPDATES FROM THE
OFFICIALS, IT NUMBER GOES UP.
THERE IS A LOT OF TRAGEDY IN
THESE MOUNTAINS AFTER THIS
FLOOD.
AND WITH THESE NEW WATERS COMING
IN, IT'S A RACE AGAINST TIME TO
TRY AND GET HELP TO PEOPLE WHO
NEED IT AND FIND PEOPLE WHO HAVE
DIED BEFORE THERE IS MORE
FLOODING COMING.
>> THE AUNT OF THOSE FOUR
CHILDREN SAID THEIR MOM AND HER
PARTNER WERE TRYING SO HARD TO
HOLD ON TO THE ARMS OF THOSE
CHILDREN AS THE FAMILY MADE ITS
WAY TO ITS ROOF BECAUSE OF THE
WATER GETTING SO HIGH THAT THE
STRENGTH OF THE WATER JUST WAS
TOO STRONG.
THEY COULDN'T HOLD ON ANY LONGER
AND THE CHILDREN WERE WASHED
AWAY.
THANK YOU, EVAN, FOR YOUR
REPORTING AND HELPING TO SHINE
LIGHT ON WHAT IS HAPPENING
THERE.
>>> ONE MOTHER SAID SHE USED THE
CORD FROM HER VACUUM CLEANER TO
TIE HERSELF TO HER WHO CHILDREN
TO KEEP THEM ALIVE.
IN THE WORST CASE OR ENSURE
THEIR BODIES WOULD BE FOUND
TOGETHER.
JESSICA SURVIVED AND SO DID HER
CHILDREN.
SHE SAYS SHE HEARD SOUNDS COMING
FROM HER HOME'S FOUNDATION JUST
BEFORE MIDNIGHT ON WEDNESDAY
EVENING.
AND WHEN SHE OPENED HER FRONT
DOOR, THIS IS WHAT SHE SAW.
WITHIN TEN MINUTES, JESSICA SAID
HER HOME WAS BEING SWEPT AWAY
AND HER CHILDREN, JUST 11 AND 3,
WERE USING THAT CORD TO STAY
TOGETHER.
JESSICA JOINS US NOW.
WOW, JESSICA.
I AM SO RELIEVED TO KNOW YOU
SURVIVED THIS, THAT YOUR
CHILDREN ARE OKAY.
BUT I KNOW YOU'VE GONE THROUGH A
LOT AND ON TRAUMATIZED.
HELP US UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENED.
HOW MUCH WARNING DID YOU HAVE?
>> I DIDN'T HAVE ANY WARNING.
I HEARD GRUNT NOISES.
WHEN I OPENED THE DOOR, THE
WATER WAS AT MY DOOR.
>> SO YOU DIDN'T EVEN NOPE THAT
THE FLOODING HAD BEGUN AT THAT
POINT, IT JUST HAPPENED THAT
QUICK?
WHAT WENT THROUGH YOUR MIND?
WHAT DO YOU DO NEXT?
>> THE FIRST THING THAT WENT
THREW MY MIND IS THAT I DIDN'T
KNOW IF WE WOULD BE SWEPT AWAY
OR NOT AND THE WORST THING I
THOUGHT WAS WHAT AM I GOING TO
DO?
I'VE GOT TO TRY TO SAVE MY KID.
SO I GRABBED TWO BATHROBE TIES
AND I TIED THEM TOGETHER AND
THAT WASN'T LONG ENOUGH SO I CUT
THE CORD OFF THE VOOEM CLEANER
AND TIED US ALL THREE TOGETHER.
BECAUSE I THOUGHT I COULD TRY TO
SAVE US OR, YOU KNOW, IF WE
DIDN'T MAKE IT, THEN WE COULD BE
FOUND ALTOGETHER.
>> AS A MOTHER, I CAN'T IMAGINE
HAVING TO THINK LIKE THAT.
WHAT MADE YOU THINK, THOUGH, TO
CUT THE CORD TO YOUR VACUUM?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I DIDN'T HAVE NOTHING ELSE.
THAT WAS THE CLOSEST THING I
COULD GET TO A ROPE.
>> YOU JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU WOULD ALL STAY TOGETHER
AND YOU DID, THANKFULLY.
>> YEAH.
>> GOSH.
I IMAGINE THIS IS JUST KIND OF
PAINFUL TO RELIVE THOSE MOMENTS.
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER YOU ALL WERE
TIED TOGETHER?
>> WE SIT IN THE LIVING ROOM FOR
A WHILE.
THE WATER WAS COMING IN.
THE FLOOR WAS DAMP.
I THOUGHT MY 3-YEAR-OLD STARTED
GETTING SCARED SO I THOUGHT LET
ME TRY TO FIND WHERE THE WATER
HADN'T COME IN YET SO WE GO INTO
MY DAUGHTER'S BEDROOM AND SAT ON
THE MATTRESS.
I THOUGHT WE WAS GOING TO RIP
APART.
YOU COULD HEAR IT POPPING AND
CRACKING AND YOU COULD FEEL IT.
I THOUGHT, WELL, IF WE WERE TO
PART, MAYBE THIS MATTRESS, WE
COULD HOLD ON TO THIS MATTRESS
AND WE WOULD MAKE IT OUT OKAY.
LUCKILY, WE GOT SANDWICHED
BETWEEN A TREE STUMP AND THE
HILLSIDE AND THAT BASICALLY
SANDWICHED US TOGETHER AND KEPT
IT FROM BEING COMPLETELY RIPPED
APART.
>> YOUR HOUSE, IT LIFTED FROM
ITS FOUNDATION, RIGHT?
AND IT STARTED TO GO DOWN WITH
THE WATER AND KIND OF LIKE A
RIVER OF WATER THAT WAS GOING BY
THERE.
IS THAT TYPICALLY A CREEK?
OR IS THAT USUALLY A ROADWAY?
WHAT WOULD NORMALLY BE WHERE WE
ARE SEEING IN THESE PICTURES
THAT WATER AND ALL OF THAT
DEBRIS?
>> THAT IS A ROAD.
MY HOUSE SIT IN FRONT OF THE
ELECTRIC POLE AND IN FRONT OF
THAT WAS A ROAD.
AND THEN IT WAS A SMALL CREEK IN
FRONT OF THAT.
BUT IT SWEPT US OFF OUR
FOUNDATION AND DOWN THE ROAD
ABOUT 100 FEET OR SO.
>> WHEN DID YOU ACTUALLY MAKE IT
OUT OF THE HOME?
>> I THINK IT WAS ABOUT 3:00 OR
4:00 OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT WHEN
I REALIZED THAT WE WERE STUCK ON
THE CLIFF.
AND THEN I COULD HEAR MUD
FALLING SO I WAS AFRAID THAT A
MUDSLIDE WAS GOING TO COME SO I
THOUGHT LET ME TRY TO GET THEM
OUT.
AND THEN I OPENED THE WINDOW IN
ISAIAH'S BEDROOM AND I COULD
SEAL THE ROAD SO WE CLIMBED OUT
OF THAT AND THEN I WALKED ABOUT
ABOUT FIVE FOOT AND THEN THERE
WAS -- THE ROADWAY WAS COVERED
WITH WATER.
SO I HAD TO LEAVE THEM THERE AND
WADE THROUGH JUST TO SEE HOW
DEEP IT WAS.
ONCE I REALIZED WE COULD GET
THROUGH, I HAD TO GO BACK FOR
THEM.
>> WOW.
NOW WHAT?
WHAT IS YOUR FAMILY'S SITUATION
CURRENTLY?
>> RIGHT NOW, I'M STAYING WITH
MY MOM.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
WE HAVE INSURANCE BUT WE DON'T
HAVE FLOOD INSURANCE BECAUSE WE
WEREN'T IN A FLOOD ZONE.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
>> I'M SO SORRY, JESSICA, FOR
THE SITUATION THAT YOU AND YOUR
FAMILY IS IN.
HAVE YOU HAD A CHANCE TO TALK TO
ANY OF YOUR NEIGHBORS?
WE KNOW THERE ARE STILL SO MANY
PEOPLE WHO ARE MISSING RIGHT NOW
AS AUTHORITIES ARE STILL
ASSESSING, YOU KNOW, WHETHER
PEOPLE MADE IT OUT AND MADE IT
TO SAFETY.
>> YEAH.
OUR LITTLE COMMUNITY, WE LOST --
THAT WE LIVE IN AND MY AUNT LOST
EVERYTHING THAT SHE HAS, TOO.
AND THERE IS JUST A BUNCH OF
THEM DOWN THERE THAT DON'T HAVE
NOTHING NO MORE AND WE DON'T
HAVE NO FLOOD INSURANCE.
I MEAN, WE WEREN'T IN A FLOOD
ZONE, SO I REALLY HOPE FEMA CAN
COME IN AND HELP US.
>> HOW ARE YOU GOING TO KEEP
GOING?
ONE DAY AT A TIME, I SUPPOSE,
HUH?
>> YEAH.
THAT THE ONLY THING I KNOW TO
DO.
>> I DO WANT TO LET OUR VIEWERS
KNOW THAT YOU'VE SET UP A GO
FUND ME AND I KNOW THAT YOU ARE
ASKING FOR ANY BIT OF HELP,
INCLUDING PRAYERS YOU SAY ON
YOUR WEBSITE HERE.
I SURE HOPE THAT PEOPLE COME TO
HELP YOUR FAMILY AND SHOW THE
GENEROSITY THAT I KNOW EXISTS
AND, PLEASE, YOU KNOW, KEEP IN
TOUCH WITH US AND WE WILL DOUGH
WHAT WE CAN ALSO TO LI